when you lead a country to victory in a
major war and maintain great popularity
throughout it would seem unlikely that
you'd immediately be voted out of office
but this is what happened to winston
churchill in the wake of world war ii
who despite being very popular lost an
election in 1945 just before japan
surrender which raises the question why
why was churchill kicked out of power
just after winning the second world war
well when germany surrendered in 1945
the british government was governed by
both the conservative and labour parties
which had formed a coalition after
elections were suspended in 1940 for the
duration of the war this suspension was
to last until the threat to the british
mainland was gone and when it was the
labour party withdrew from the coalition
elections were scheduled for early july
and so both sides immediately started
drawing up manifestos to put to the
people the conservative plan was simple
churchill he was seen as the face of
british victory over germany and the
conservative party focused on his
foreign policy credentials as being able
to secure the empire and also give
britain an enhanced position within the
new world that was emerging beyond this
churchill's plans for britain were a
part of what were known as the four-year
plan this was co-authored by both
parties and it promised the creation of
a national health service funded by a
new national insurance tax the expansion
of agricultural production to reduce
food imports and the rebuilding of the
country after all those bombs had been
dropped on it whereas the labour party
also promised the creation of a national
health service the rebuilding of the
country the expansion of educational
opportunities but importantly they also
promised to massively reduce
unemployment which was especially
important given how many soldiers were
returning home so why did labour win
when the policies were so similar well
whilst churchill was very popular he was
seen as a great wartime leader and not a
peacetime one throughout the coalition
the labour party hadn't been in charge
of running the war but running britain
domestically and the people had seen
them as being quite good at it they had
also importantly joined the government
in 1940 and so they weren't tarnished by
the failure of appeasement like the
conservatives were also broadly the
british people wanted radical change you
see the war kind of sucked and so people
wanted to build a much better system
after its end many of them felt that
churchill and his colleagues wouldn't do
that in the same way that labour leader
clemently would churchill also made the
mistake of thinking that the british
people hated all things socialist like
they had done in the past since it was
no longer associated primarily with
revolution and killing monarchs it was
now seen as a vital part of germany's
defeat and people like joseph stalin
maintained great popularity in the uk
and as such when churchill said that a
labour victory would lead to a new
gestapo in britain it hurt his electoral
chances and throughout the campaign the
conservatives made no attempt to change
course despite polling 20 points behind
the labour party for the entire thing so
why didn't they change well it was
simple they didn't believe the polls and
when the election was over conservative
leaders were shocked to find out that
not only had they lost they'd suffered
the greatest upset in their party's
history and thus despite his immense
popularity with the british people
churchill was kicked out of office just
after world war ii i hope you enjoyed
this episode and a special thanks to my
patrons james bissonette kelly
moneymaker sky chappelle caution wolf
jerry landon jordan longley adam stalter
marcus arsenault wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot rod d martin words about books
podcast captain cydog gustav swan marvin
castle common yoon winston k wood
bugilly wiggly daniel to be in miss
izzette aaron the white corey turner the
mcwhopper alex schwinn anthony beckett
coppertone maggie patzkowski schuenin
spinning three plates and charles the
first